all right so notion I wanted to do
another sponsored video so I thought
this would be a good opportunity to talk
about how we kind of organized the
development of Hazel because that
genuinely involves notion long story
short notion is a productivity app that
is kind of like a note-taking app but
it's like so much more than that it's
obviously not the only tool that we use
but it actually acts as a really good
Hub to bring other tools together and
there's so many kind of little gaps that
it fills in that it actually ends up
just being open on my computer like
minimized at all times because I just
find myself using it so often so in this
video I'm just going to show you a
little bit about how notion is used in
my kind of workflow and also like the
other apps and platforms that we use to
organize Hazel's software development
foreign so first and foremost notion I
mentioned that it stays open on my
computer a lot of the time and the
reason for that is truthful firstly if I
need to write something down like I want
to take some notes or just like take a
little screenshot of something or paste
in an image that's kind of where I do it
I just put it into notion now I used to
just like open notepad for that just
because it's so quick to just hit the
Windows key type in notepad and just
paste stuff in but the problem with that
is that unless it's like a really really
transient kind of temporary note it's
probably going to wind up getting lost
but with notion with something a little
bit more serious you know I can easily
just like categorize it add it to like a
page even like create links between
pages to keep stuff organized I can have
these like toggleable headings as well
aside from just being able to paste in
any kind of content you could really
imagine I can also embed like entire web
pages so like even if they just get
taken down or go offline or whatever in
the future I can literally just like be
reading an article and be like hey
notion I want to embed all the contents
of this webpage and it will do it and it
works everywhere I remember some people
saying that like notion stores your data
on the cloud therefore it's bad and I'm
like no no that's the point like I get
it maybe if you have some really
sensitive data you maybe don't want to
trust like having it sold on the cloud
you want to be completely offline maybe
you want something like obsidian and
that's cool between you and me I have
like a secret uh personal Journal that I
keep an obsidian but for like work stuff
it's just so convenient to be able to
pull it up on your laptop like on your
phone I have an iPad as well that I like
to use for taking down notes and it's
just so great to just have everything
synced between all your devices I mean I
really shouldn't be telling you guys
this like it's life in the cloud has
been pretty good the past like decade or
so and as I mentioned for meetings like
I like to take down notes of meetings I
might just like sit on the couch have a
meeting with Peter all the way over in
Sweden just take notes on my laptop and
they're all obviously available on my
desktop it's basically like a Google doc
so that's probably like my number one
use case for notion it's like I just
need take down some notes I need to
organize some documentation I need to
make sure I don't forget about those
bugs and Hazel Peter sent me something
cool let me check that out but I can't
check it out right now so maybe I'll
just file it away all of like I mean
just looking at what I have a notion
like all the meeting notes from like all
of our past meetings which is good to
chase up work and make sure it's getting
done and issues aren't being forgotten
about planning stuff like planning
stuff's really useful like I have like I
do a lot of stuff for hazel obviously
like when I was planning like the new
kind of renderer for hazel it was just
great to be able to you know write stuff
down here make sure that I don't forget
anything as well paste and like
screenshots you know links to kind of
good articles tied in with like a an
eventual kind of video idea that I want
to like make with my findings but then
the other like really useful use case I
think for notion at least for me is just
the fact that it integrates like with
everything like you know I have all of
these jira issues for example and we'll
talk about jira a little bit later in
this video but like all of the issues
that are being tracked like for hazel I
can just see them right here in notion I
can have like this kind of welcome page
that is just like my hub for like hey
it's a Monday morning or whatever I have
no idea what's going on because the
weekend just happened I need to get back
into work like where is everything like
what's happening what are the tasks like
what are the latest commits that have
gone into Hazel like from the rest of
the team where are my quick little links
to like open up all the stuff that I
need to I don't know like what's the
weather right now like what's my
calendar looking like you know all of
this stuff you can just put into like a
little like a welcome page in notion and
obviously this is just one way to use
these Integrations but I like doing that
I actually got the idea from Tim because
it means I can just kind of open up a
single page and just see an overview of
what's happening it's like having a home
page for your web browser but this is
like a home page for your life or your
work or whatever it is you care about so
from an organizational point of view
like I really have to say that notion
kind of acts as like a central
repository for like all the information
that I want to store but then it's also
like a central place that ties in
everything else so like you know jira I
don't know Google Docs and documentation
like all the kind of GitHub stuff as
well I can tie in all that into notion
it becomes kind of like a starting point
it integrates really nicely with jira
because you can see all I have to do is
paste a link to a jira issue a notion
and it will display it nicely and kind
of even give me some of the information
about it now there are several tiers of
notion but the free tier is like
honestly has pretty much all the
features you could probably want if
you're just working by yourself if
you're in a team notion plus is a really
good plan to take a look at but
otherwise for most of you like the free
tier of notion will probably have like
everything you need the only downside I
would say for like a solar user would be
you can only have one synced database
which means that if you want to have
like jira issues but then you also want
to have like your GitHub commit like
your calendar or something automatically
synced like you can only do that to one
thing and that's where an operator might
make sense but definitely head on over
to ntn.so Cherno and just try out notion
you can try it out for free as I
mentioned the free tier is great and
notion has sponsored this video so a
huge thank you to them
[Music]
now as good as Martian is for like
taking notes and all that stuff if I
have like a little bit more of a serious
document to write I'll usually use
Google Docs the way I see it is that
even though I definitely enjoy using
notion a little bit more just because I
can use all of these blocks just by like
typing in slash and it's kind of just a
more I don't know fluent way to write
notes I guess because kind of like
markdown and you don't have to like keep
clicking on formatting options and stuff
like that it also has a dark mode just
like out of the box which Google Docs
like I mean it's not that's not that
easy to set up but the way I see it is
that if it's like a long long document
that really should be divided into kind
of pages that you maybe even print and
also as a benefit it kind of has that
like real-time collaboration out of the
box as well for that kind of stuff it's
really useful like I might ask Xerox for
example this happened recently when he
was working on the animation system like
hey can you please put together like a
dock of this new process that you're
proposing you know he even did something
similar thing for quaternions when he
was trying to convert a few things that
were still in Euler angles like into
quaternions in in Hazel they threw
together like a little dot I love the
fact that Google Docs can just be
exported to PDFs like immediately that
makes it really really really simple to
just write something send it to someone
and it's just like a regular document so
like for documents Google Docs like I
love using that
now the final piece of the puzzle is
jira so atlassian jira is like an issue
tracking kind of platform I guess you
know it's really funny because so we
used to use jira at EA I mean well I'm
sure they still use it but back when I
worked at EA like we used jira for our
issue tracking and I hated it because as
like a software engineer I just kind of
wanted to write like the code and then
it's kind of like oh make sure you're
logging your time in jira make sure that
you make a jira for every issue like
we'd have these development directors
DDS they were called and their job was
solely to basically like I mean they
kind of oversaw the production of it it
didn't help that back then in the Osiris
days when I was working on the mobile
internet EA for the longest time it felt
like none of the DDS actually had any
idea like really what a game engine was
they were just like they had worked on
games in the past but not game engines
and so there was this weird like our
technical director which is have
arguments in meetings like with all of
the whole team there with the DD being
like no actually you have no idea what
you're talking about there's not having
this works like how do you not know what
this is and it was just hilarious but
anyway the point is these DDS would
always be like make sure you're logging
your jiras make sure you do this and
that and it was just everyone hated jira
but now now that I am like the technical
director of Hazel and we don't have a
development director and I'm kind of
also I guess in charge of overseeing the
development of the project I love I
actually really like jira I mean it's
different maybe because it's obviously a
lot less corporate than like something
like EA there's teams also a lot smaller
but jira is free for like up to 10
people in fact a lot of atlassian
products like a Confluence which we used
to use at EA we don't actually use this
in Hazel at the moment but I'm
considering it that's also free up to 10
people so if you guys are in a small
team like I highly recommend you do
check out some of these atlassian
products and jira being an issue tracker
basically what that means is that every
single little task or bug that we're
working on in Hazel we can basically
make an issue for it we can like
estimate how long it will take to fix
that we can make sure that people are
assigned to it we can make sure people
are actually working on it it's really
useful for me as like the project
manager to be able to see kind of like
this roadmap view which I love which
just shows you like hey here are all of
the epics which are kind of like I guess
collections of tasks that form like one
a huge kind of task so it might be
something like a release version or a
major feature and it's made up of all
these tiny tasks but I can kind of see
what the time commitment for that is and
just make sure that like if we're trying
to release something you know by
December this year for example like
we're gonna make it and obviously
nothing is going to get overlooked like
it's not going to be like oh I
completely forgot about that bug or I
didn't do this because it's all kind of
tracked it's all organized and this kind
of visual view is also really really
useful it's also really good for me to
just rock up on a Monday morning as I
said before with the whole notion Hub
situation like it's really good for me
to rock up on a Monday morning and be
like what on Earth is the team currently
doing and just being able to kind of see
I guess Peter's working on this you know
zero X is kind of finishing up his
animation thing hopefully this week
that's really useful obviously as long
as you your team actually keeps their
jira out up to date that's really useful
because it means that I don't have to
chase off everyone and be like hey Peter
how's this going are you almost done
with that or what are you currently
working on I have no idea now there are
alternatives to jira again as like we
use jira in a free capacity and to be
honest it's so good that like if I was
paying for it I'd also probably be happy
there are other Alternatives like if
you're on git lab you could use gitlab
issues if you're on GitHub the kind of
Studio Channel repositories are
currently hosted on GitHub like we could
use GitHub issues obviously for this
kind of stuff uh there's a couple of
reasons why we use jira one of them is
because we kind of keep the development
of Hazel internal meaning that like only
people who are in the studio Channel
organization actually have access to
this kind of stuff because we want to
separate Community issues from internal
issues but also because I like in my
opinion like I think jira is far
superior to GitHub issues I mean jira is
like a whole platform made for this kind
of issue tracking stuff whereas GitHub
even though like they have definitely
expanded on their features for issue
tracking it still feels like a little
kind of add-on to a repository rather
than like I'm managing this huge
software project please give me all of
these tools so that's why we use and
love jira
all right that's it hope that was
helpful hope you guys learned a little
something about our workflow a workflow
that is still very much under
construction might I add I am still what
I consider to be very bad at running
things here having these tools in place
and these workflows are really really
important because I'm a very busy man on
one hand I'm building and leading the
development of a game engine which that
by itself is not easy but then I'm also
running a YouTube channel making sure
that I make videos like this one to fund
development of said engine and that's
just the work side of things in my life
so if I've learned anything in the last
like four years since I left EA and am
now working for myself and I am the boss
now is that stuff needs to be organized
stuff needs to go into notion or jira or
Google Docs or wherever it is because if
it doesn't it either wastes time or it
gets forgotten about and neither of
those two things are good in fact I'm
pretty sure I lost a bill and I need to
request that again so I can pay it
anyway I highly encourage that you guys
take a look at notion if you haven't
already you can get started absolutely
for free just go to ntn.so channel the
link will be in the description below
give it a go it's a really good way to
organize your life and your work just to
organize the chaos really alright I'll
see you guys next time goodbye